Okay, folks.
We are alive.
I do wonder whether this microphone is
going to be in a good spot here.
I've kind of moved it.
Um
I'll put it here and you can let me
know.
Plan is to just do a a short stream and
work on I think
we're going to go check on the sweep
data from Sokoban.
And uh we're going to maybe look at the
RS environment.
And then that's pretty much it. We're
taking it easy for a few days here.
Thanks, Pepe.
I've been working with um
I hired two different artists.
I uh
I had to fire one of them this morning.
Uh just
like not a usable idea. I did pay him
though.
Um
We have one artist left and maybe we're
going to get one additional backup. But
this guy's been pretty good.
Like some of the stuff needs work, but
uh he takes the feedback and he's quite
talented.
Blender
Oh, I have lots of stuff to show off,
Pepe. I I'm going to wait until it's
actually done though. The face on it's
really dopey. We got to fix it.
This is going to be a short stream
because today I have
not one
but two clients open.
It is uh leagues.
It is an event that they host like once
a year.
And I've been having a ton of fun with
it and it's perfectly timed for a little
bit of post 40
vacation. So I'm just going to integrate
a couple community-made environments, do
a couple small things for clients, test
out a couple things here and there, run
some sweeps. Other than that, I'm
chilling for a bit.
Hey, Muffin.
All right, let's see how we've done on
Sokoban.
Good bro. Thanks, Muffin.
Yeah, let me know anything that just
doesn't work in uh in Discord. I'm
trying to do little fixes and stuff as
well.
We've already merged in a few new
environments if you haven't noticed.
Let's see if we get any new results for
Tim here.
Oh ha.
Uh he's going to be happy.
Yeah, he's going to be happy about this.
I think I just keep letting it go then,
huh?
So um
we got 56% on Sokoban.
Okay, so it is leveling out here, you
see?
I basically just did a couple fixes to
the environment and this just worked.
Um I didn't really mess with his end at
all. I kind of just like fixed a couple
tiny things and just ran a sweep.
And then we started out under 1%
and we got up to 56%.
Which was I think it ate your first
message, Tim.
You eat
eat
Wait, what?
You eval the sweep.
Uh I'm almost certain that I fixed it so
that the sweep will eval correctly, Tim.
I can set something up though for us.
I need to get I need to train something
though.
Here, we'll do this.
All right. Well, we'll see. I think I
fixed that though, Tim. I'm pretty sure.
So, here you go. This is a 4.9 mil S 4.9
mil parameter network training at 2.7
mil SPS.
I don't see any way that it could be
hacking it at this point though. I will
say.
So, Vala also said that he pushed some
stuff.
Do I have any other M's that I should be
messing with at the moment because
I guess John's.
Maybe John has his one.
See if we have John's PR yet.
This is Vala's.
So, yeah, we don't have John's M yet.
John's M would be nice to have.
I like this. It's a 300 PR though. I
don't feel like doing more merges right
now.
We will obviously do more of them, but
Oh, and I'm using this box for another 6
minutes, right?
I guess I can just run it locally, can't
I?
Yeah.
I think it's supposed to be very
obvious.
Like
I don't know.
I mean the thing is like
if you don't need capital, you don't
need investment at all.
What is this? Why why are we way over
here?
Oh, are we actually hitting Zach?
Uh we're barraging Zach and we're going
to get clapped in a moment here.
I just
always proper limited
Well, A3C is not better for that. No.
A3C is just newbie version of this.
Um it's not really limited liberty. It's
just like
we don't have a bunch of integrations
for existing robotic stuff.
And a lot of robotics is dependent on a
really dense brittle stacks of stuff.
Like if you just write a control sim,
it'll work. If you write a high
dimensional control sim that's fast,
it'll probably work.
Probably. I don't think there's any
reason it shouldn't.
Okay, so Tim, this stop matches exactly
what we expected.
I suppose you have to see it to believe
it.
Fair enough.
Really?
Hang on.
Um for this by the way. So, it's not
like amazing.
Oh, it can't go through this.
Interesting.
That was quite close. It got three of
them.
This to me looks like it very well could
be 10% solve rate. Let's see.
Oh, that was smart.
Oh.
Boom. There. It did it.
It just got one.
Some reason here it has no idea what to
do.
Uh this is much harder than mazes.
Like much much harder than mazes.
I know because we also have a maze
environment a maze environment we use
extensively.
PR review
It depends what you have PR'd.
Ooh.
First level 90 on leagues.
So, you can see what I've been doing in
my off time here.
We have enough maze environments. We
need a maze environment.
So, Tim, this looks like 10% to me.
So, this repros just fine.
The earlier versions didn't repro until
I did those end fixes.
Yeah, no, that was a thing, Tim. The old
version before those fixes transferred
badly.
If you just didn't clear out your cache,
you probably have all the old data and
all the new data in your sweeps.
No, no, no. It was a bug before.
So, the old sweeps, it was really bad.
Um because it was logging like the first
success. So, it was logging a 100%
success rate just by doing a really
short experiments.
I think that this is a 10%
success rate as it says. This looks like
what is claimed.
Get drunk key.
Um, I mean considering the env I'm most
excited about that's going to be the
best env ever as follows RS environment,
yeah.
Have you seen This is my side monitor at
the moment.
The RS env freaked me out.
Which one?
move count.
We think about that.
I really, really would like to get the
eval for um
the inferno and four king.
If I can just figure that out today.
Episode length is 352.
352 is supposed to be a few minutes,
right?
Actually, we can Here's what we can do.
This dude just sits there, right?
Yeah, look. Doesn't learn anything. So,
this is expected.
Okay, well, that's weird. It straight up
doesn't train in torch.
I don't know if there's a masking
difference just like I think he did some
weird action masking stuff.
Which could totally be it cuz it doesn't
even seem like it wants to move on eval.
Here.
I know what we're going to do.
Like not be stupid about this, right?
Well, this thing is just wasting money.
So, [ __ ] off.
Nice Malach madude.
You got this Malach here for
Oh, do we stand behind this shield now?
Or do we just run around like do
nothing?
Oh.
No.
Are we behind the shield?
Dude, we're behind the shield. [ __ ] yes.
Yeah, we're behind the shield.
All right.
Sixten latest.
I can work with this [ __ ]
This is You know what? I will stream a
little bit longer cuz this is the
coolest [ __ ] ever.
That's not me.
That's the agent doing the zerk.
Wait, how are you going to handle this
set?
We're going to handle the set. We're
going to tag the major, I see.
You kind of don't want to tag the major.
Oh, yeah, it's using prayer quickly. So,
I assume it has rigor.
No, but I don't see rigor on.
It's flicking its prayers. Nice.
Oh, okay. It's just going to flick both
of them because it's a Chad. Okay.
It's literally learning the
Oh, no, no, no, no, it's not. Okay.
Wait. Huh?
Okay, now we now it's going to tag the
ranger.
Okay, it's got the barrage on him, but
it's fine.
Yo, you going to blowpipe this dude or
not?
We're just going to not tag the ranger,
huh?
So, for anybody who doesn't know what
the hell's going on here,
uh the shield is taking damage
and it's not going to win before it
beats it takes the shield down.
Blister bow on ranger not ideal.
We're going to mage.
Why are we freezing the ranger?
Well, I guess it doesn't matter except
now you're going to get zerked.
Oh, get zerked.
It'll be a lot easier if you just kill
the Yeah, there you go. Kill the ranger.
Cool.
All right, we're going to get
That was a
range [ __ ]
That was a range [ __ ] Okay, flicking
the range [ __ ] Good.
We're going to flick our gear for the
hell of it, it looks like.
That's the range attack.
But then it's firing the major orb.
Uh we have not tagged the healers.
We're going to tag the healers.
445 health.
We might just not be tagging healers,
yeah.
Because we're farming reward off of
doing damage.
Yeah, we're farming reward off doing
damage.
Not going to fight the healer this year,
huh?
Oh, wait, he vows super smooth now as
well, I just noticed. So, he fixed that.
All right. Well, I think I get it. We're
basically we're just farming reward off
of um
off of Jad.
And we're not going to actually do
anything else.
So, I see what he tried to do, but this
is not sufficient.
>> It takes a little longer. We still learn
to stay behind the shield, though.
All right, so we actually have to come
up with like a reasonable not stupid
reward here, don't we? Cuz it's clearing
the way which is good for everything
except Zuk.
if it just learns to kill everything, it
actually might just work on Zuk.
Oh, it won.
It literally it won.
All right, we run it for 250 and we full
solve hopefully.
Actually, I'm going to do I just forgot
to recording.
Well, I can just clip it from the
stream, can I?
All right, this should be
the uh
Hang on.
This is all set up here.
All right.
This should be the first ever Zuk
completion
by reinforcement learning.
This is still recognizable gameplay.
It doesn't need to be flicking tank and
[ __ ] constantly.
And it's moving like
pretty erratically.
But it does dip in front of the shield
when it needs to be.
All right, who are we tagging? Are we
tagging Ranger?
No, we still like to tag major for some
reason.
Maybe that is the play. I don't know.
Major does a lot of damage to shield.
Maybe it just hasn't figured out
blowpipe.
Does flick its range gear on for the
hits.
What we want.
It doesn't tag the Ranger interestingly.
So, it has not bothered to learn how to
flick both of them.
You really should tag the Ranger, my
guy.
We're not going to wait to pause the set
timer, surely.
Okay, blowpipe.
Two tick blowpipe?
I think that was three tick.
I think it's three ticking its blowpipe.
But that's the right weapon, good.
That is correct Inferno gameplay.
Probably should not be bowing in your
justy.
Probably not what you want to do, agent.
So, I can't really tell with the
animations.
I think it is bowing in justy. I can't
tell if it's flicking it at the right
tick or not.
It really doesn't even need the justy
for this, honestly.
Or the mage gear for just the final
wave.
It has used three doses of bastion at
this point, which is not good. And three
doses of stam.
It has not touched its bruise.
Uh it also has zero
It's flicking prayers on with zero
prayer points.
I think that's a sim bug.
Not that it matters. It has plenty of
prayer to just camp.
Oh, no. There it goes.
It's restoring.
Okay.
Doing Jad.
We're going to tag healers. I want to
see how it tags the healers.
Is it going to just tag them with the
bow?
Did it barrage them or did it tag with
the bow?
What? Why are there only two?
Shouldn't there be like six?
Okay, there's something up with the Jad
healers.
But
how did it just hit a 49 on the Jad
healer?
Can you bow a 49 on Jad healers? I don't
think so.
Is it blood barraging?
Doesn't need to do that.
Wait, how's the shield taking damage?
Oh, okay, it wasn't.
That was a hit splat on one of the
healers.
Okay, I don't know why it's trying to
kill the healers, though.
Or why it's bowing Zuk.
I mean, it's fine to bow Zuk while
you're doing Jad, to be fair. Yeah, that
was a hit splat on the um
Oh, it's blood barraging the shield.
I will have Vault fix that.
Also, one of the healers is stuck under
Jad. That's fine.
Okay.
Oops.
Uh
HP.
Why is Jad not dying?
Okay.
Dead.
So, I mean, we're definitely slow here.
We're going to get another set.
Maybe before healers.
Surely we get another set before
healers, right?
I would wait here. I would not proc
healers on this
HP. Um
I would wait for the set.
Is it waiting?
Wait, does it actually know to wait for
the set?
Or is it going to bow?
That's actually really solid.
I would not expect it to know to wait.
Immediately tags the mage.
Shield HP is fine.
Since it tagged mage first.
Ranger cannot kill this before it kills
the major.
Okay, we're not bastioned.
We should be bastion potioning here.
Are we saving it for post healers?
I didn't even know you could drag the
ranger like that. That's weird.
Okay.
We got blowpipe.
And
we spec.
I didn't see if we just spec'd there or
not, but we're good now.
Okay, now we are good to send healers.
This is good health.
Rock healers, tag.
Tag.
I don't know why we're tagging them with
ice barrage.
We're dodging.
Wait, we've taken no damage so far from
the healer splats.
Geez, it's gaming.
Okay, it takes a little damage.
Yeah, it's That's freaking solid.
I don't know why it's doing these with
ice barrage
instead of blowpipe.
I actually don't know what ice barrage
DPS is on healers.
I'd be shocked if it's better than
blowpipe.
With Misori, yeah, no way. But without
bastion potion and if it doesn't know
how to use rigor,
then maybe.
Healers are down.
And then this should just be an easy
Zuck.
Oh, is there some bug with killing it?
It might be farming.
It might actually be farming here.
Oh, that's so funny.
All right, it needs uh
I mean, that's completed though. Like
It left it on one bow shot.
Come on, just hit it.
So tempted to just like
help it here.
You know, I don't think I can take over
for it and hit it.
I can't.
Okay, it is just farming sets then.
Maybe it will kill it though when um
the shield HP gets low. I think that's
probably what it'll do.
I think it did. I think it was just
playing around too much.
All right, bow Zuck.
You know you need the bow Zuck.
Okay, we're both a ranger.
That works.
Cuz it knows the shield HP is low.
So it actually reward farmed and it
still wins.
Huh.
That's too close to Sea of Stars, the
game.
I couldn't name it Sea of Stars.
Already taken by an awesome game.
Oh, that is Zuck.
Uh I got to link vault the clip.
Bro.
Where's the button to like
Why does YouTube do this? Like they used
to have a button here
that you used to be able to say start
from whenever.
See if this actually works for um
the main inferno.
I mean, this is nice like sweep
territory, right?
Say box of an is done, I can just sweep
on the main box.
5 mil SPS. If anything, that's slow,
man. We can go way faster.
Hello. How's it going, Tenma?
Today is a RuneScape and RL day.
We got the first ever RL policy that can
beat Jad
just on the one wave on its own.
And um
now I'm trying to see if I can get this
thing set up to do
the whole Inferno.
So, why not?
Okay, it looks like it helped slightly
to give it the uh wave completion bonus.
I think ultimately we'll be able to
train it to just complete the waves.
We'll see.
Can't beat a single level on Inferno.
There's no way you can't beat the first
level.
level of Inferno.
It's kind of funny. I figured I would
just do a chill stream, work on this a
little bit, set some stuff up, and just
AFK'ing the uh
I've been having a ton and ton of fun
with the leagues.
The uh the new uh demonic packs league.
That is my vacation from 400 release.
When I run out of stuff to AFK, the
stream ends.
I don't have a mouse. Ah.
Dude.
How many different aspects of the game
do you need to reward you the proper to
train the Inferno?
Is that going down? So, um Vault added
several. I actually deleted some of his
rewards.
I think ultimately we will be able to
train it with just wave completion
reward,
and we might have to tweak it a little
bit on Jad,
um because of the healers, Jad or Jad.
I don't know if we're going to have to
do something about that, just cuz it's a
really long fight.
But I think that we can do the entire
thing, at least up until Jad's,
with just wave completion,
after we've tuned it a bit.
Yeah, this is wave 36 in 3 minutes.
Oh yeah, like if you look
Like here, let me show you one of this.
So, like Vault added a survival reward
and a stay behind the shield reward, and
I just commented them. They're not
needed.
The only thing I had to do is I had to
tweak his damage reward a little bit,
but then that's literally all it needed.
So, that's actually one reward for um
Jad.
Just need one reward.
It would be nice to just have it be
sparse. It's kind of tough.
It's not like a super satisfying reward
because it's it's the just the amount of
damage you deal minus the amount of
health that the enemies heal.
You need that cuz otherwise it'll just
farm uh farm damage and not kill the
healers.
I guess the observations thing. I didn't
even get to change, huh?
Models big. Upper is still pretty good
with the bigger models just
Like we have native BF16 now is really
good.
Yeah, so you get introduced to the major
at 35.
Did you manage to simplify? I simplified
the obs, but then we have to merge the
stuff together. So I'm going to chat
with Vault and we'll figure something
out.
Cuz we got to figure out how to merge
some stuff.
I want to show him this as well.
All right. So this is starting from the
major waves.
Uh wave 1 to 35 are kind of just like
gimmies
anyways. So if we can solve this, we can
solve the full thing.
Difference is minimal.
Full distillation.
That for that is
that is fair.
Okay. So wave 49
Starting at 35, we get to 49
I do wonder. Let's just try one last
thing and then we'll set up a sweep.
Give it some brews. I mean we'll take
away its brews.
I just want to see what it does if I
take away its brews.
Plans for next version?
Uh it's algorithmic for the most part,
but it's it says
it is an algorithmic change that
requires some redesigning of the
environment interface.
It's around
it's around state sets.
Um
I don't want to talk too much about it
until I actually get to start on it
properly, which will not be until I have
had some good time to rest.
Which in my book means
I get to play some league.
League is not League of Legends.
Runescape league
temporary accelerated XP game mode with
a whole bunch of crazy [ __ ]
I've been having a lot of fun with it.
It came out yesterday.
Hibernation?
Just this is kind of hibernation in the
sense that I'm just I'm doing I've been
live for 2 hours. I'm not going to be
live more than another hour tops unless
Vault comes back and wants to look at
Inferno.
And then I just chill.
I mean I'm probably still going to do
like a couple hours here and there on
some M's just fiddling with some stuff,
but I'm doing chill stuff, right? I'm
not like
I'm not going to really start thinking
all the way about 5 L algorithm stuff
for a while.
Okay, look at this.
Literally
the brews are redundant.
If you don't give it brews, it just
learns to blood barrage.
>> Okay, so this is 49
1900 steps, right?
49 1700 steps. Okay, the brews are
completely useless.
I mean, I guess we could give it 32
bastion doses.
That might be nice, right? 32 bastion
doses.
Maybe it'll learn something with that.
And then we'll run a sweep.
It did build, right? Yes.
They built.
We could give them um
forgotten brews for magic.
That probably doesn't help much, though.
Diverse in their solutions.
Absolutely not, Jess. I've done a whole
bunch of stuff in that.
Nope, doesn't work.
Um
The self-play stuff is going to be
pretty good for that, though, I think.
At least it's a start.
I wonder if the bastions are even
helpful.
It should be pretty easy to ration
those, like
you don't need
eight potions.
How many would you need actually to like
just do that every few minutes?
I mean, literally, you could just one of
those every minute or two and you'll be
good.
So
I tried like Diane and stuff. It's
They're all based on really crappy
heuristics and whatnot.
I have not been able to get any of the
stuff to replicate. A lot of them add a
bunch of train time
or they're just based on training
populations and hoping that they end up
learning different things
or that you get different behaviors out
of different hyper parameters.
There really has not been anything that
just actually works well
as shown on paper
from what I've seen.
You also don't necessarily need
different agents to do different stuff,
like
you kind of just need agents to be
flexible and to be able to slightly
condition them into different behaviors.
Like, I think goal conditioning is a
really good way to get diverse
behaviors.
If you can just sort of specify
different
like slightly different objectives or
whatnot,
then you get way more general policies.
That seems more effective to me.
But the episode length went down a
little bit.
Actually, what's the inventory that they
take for um
What's the inventory the speed runners
take?
Divine if going for a fast.
Right, because divine range pots.
That's plenty of time.
Yeah, so we could give it There's a lot
of stuff we can upgrade for it actually
in the gear.
I think we'll just set this up as a
sweep.
And
set that up and then I'll do that.
>> something up and then we'll uh continue.
At least that
I guess we will just do um
start from wave 35 for now.
All right.
There.
we try to sweep this one on the tiny
box.
Also, has Vault replied to this?
No.
Patch.
Box have been done sweeping for now.
Dr. Mario is training in 25-ish minutes.
43 mil SPS.
Oh, you can do way faster than that, my
guy.
They're adding sprites.
Next stream?
Yeah, of course.
Get something to reasonably put together
so I can actually ideally get something
that I can actually just very easily,
you know,
uh either PR and then like just download
or like pull or just some clone it a
standalone something
that I can just train it and I can futz
with it.
Cuz usually I can find a lot of stuff
for people when I can futz with stuff.
Nice.
Inferno.
I don't know how the [ __ ] that compiled.
I have no idea how that compiles, but
that's totally wrong.
Local scoping.
So, you have a a variable called score
outside of a loop,
and then you can still define it locally
inside of a loop.
I actually don't really like local
scoping rules in general. Like I could
probably be convinced on this,
but
I I don't see the need to have the scope
be restricted
to like I like I don't see why you can't
define something inside of a loop
and use it outside of a loop.
So, to be fair, there might actually be
a technical reason for the compiler you
can't do that. I don't think there is
one.
Like do that fast, obviously, I mean.
>> All right.
Hopefully this is good.
Man, SPS is not a dick. Lovely.
My guy, you do not need any of this
garbage.
Literally don't need any of this.
Streaming for the next 5 to 6 hours?
Nope, Anish. I am chilling today.
I am actually going to be done in half
an hour tops.
Maybe less.
I'm just doing some short streams, you
know? And then I'm chilling for the most
part.
I'm kind of just doing some simple stuff
that I'm having fun with.
And I got uh the Runescape environment
running here on six boxes.
Let me tell Vault.
Next stream I'm inducting myself and my
bro to the proper Hall of Fame.
Hey, look forward to it.
We like NFPRs.
This freaking inferno environment is
just the coolest [ __ ] ever, man.
I kind of just want to watch the
freaking model.
Oh, yeah, we're just going to stand in
the center,
speed run tech,
hit the major,
not give a [ __ ] about our pillars.
All right, let's see what we do. Oops,
it feels a little weird.
I mean, it is just standing right in the
center.
Yeah, some of the anims are so are super
screwed up, for sure.
>> To be fair, you don't really care about
that pillar that they're on there that
much.
It is learning just to preserve its
potions as well.
It has not
even sipped a bastion though.
Freaking crystal shield life.
Going to give it some better gear than
this.
I already see game last week mimic GTA V
in 50 p. It was fun.
C is chill.
C is very chill.
All right, come on. This is troll. You
have to at least tag the nibblers.
Okay.
That's a just a quick cash troll barrage
on the nibs.
So yeah, it's just going to be standing
center of inferno and flick perfectly,
right?
Okay, it is blow piping the blob.
It actually is using the correct
weapons.
Spencer
we beat Zuck.
Just Zuck. Just the last wave. We have
not beaten the whole thing yet, but we
beat Zuck in like 3 minutes of training.
I've basically been having a ton of fun
playing a bunch of Runescape and
training a bunch of Runescape agents.
All right. Uh blowpipe on bat is
reasonable.
We're going to barrage nibblers.
Bat gets resurrected.
Be killed again. Yeah, okay.
There's still one nibbler on the pillar.
You really really should hit that
nibbler before you bother with the mage.
It just went to do it and it didn't.
Come on. Blowpipe.
Okay, mage hit. There we go.
Why are we blow piping? Oh yeah, the
blob. Good.
Oh, did you see that? It learned to blob
freeze.
It learned to blob freeze.
I This is the first task where I
actually have an understanding of the
complexity of this thing. And like
puffer is way better than I thought it
was. If it can just do this in 2 minutes
Jeez.
Perfect blood barrage on the on the
blobs.
Yeah, I It's not Oh, I understand. It
doesn't give a [ __ ] about its pillars
because it doesn't It literally doesn't
need them. It's just good enough that it
just doesn't care.
But there are sometimes when you really
do want those.
It actually knows to kill the major
first so that the major doesn't res the
blobs.
So I mean the crazy thing about this
right here is like it doesn't know
everything yet, but this is above
grandmaster gameplay.
Like
at least portions of it are above GM
gameplay.
Want this part reward function is too
better. We don't have a fancy reward
function.
There are a couple small things, but
it's like almost entirely beat the wave
do damage.
I mean it could just not res the mailer,
I guess.
Where did that nibbler come from? Was it
just frozen? I didn't see it.
If this thing gets sub 65
I'm probably going to have to do it as
well.
I game deployed it.
Sure.
What's the link? Well, YouTube might not
let you link it, but you can drop it in
the discord.
But it's draining really quickly for not
using offensives.
Interesting. It blood barrages the
nibblers
cuz it was low on HP instead of
freezing.
Oh, is the mailer trapped on the
nibbler?
Yes, it works.
Oh, the major is respawning nibbler.
That's not allowed.
Get.
Okay, we took a hit.
But it really just doesn't give a [ __ ]
huh?
It's just fine flicking major blob, I
guess.
Yeah, I think it just doesn't care.
It'll just flick major blob
and then it'll just freeze melee.
Is it going to take the It's like
thinking about blow piping the nibbler.
But then it just doesn't. Yeah, see it's
getting a free pass here cuz the major
keeps res summoning nibblers
instead of summoning like the melee
back.
Oh, it has actually used its bastion
potions.
Uh major stuck in pillar.
Or melee stuck in pillar.
But like you can kind of just watch it
at this point.
Okay, so it has no bruise.
Okay, so it's blood barraging [ __ ]
But it's taking damage because
All right.
So,
what do you do here?
You're on 37 health.
Are we barraging it? No, we're
still T-bowing it.
Are we going to use the pillar now?
Uh it's getting blood barrage healing.
It's flicking. What's it flicking? Two
blobs major?
Okay.
Go back to 37 health.
What are we doing?
Oh, okay. Major's dead.
So, major is going to Wait, the blobs
are going to split.
Is it going to blood barrage this
correctly?
I'll check Discord, Johnny, after it
dies.
Ooh, okay.
71 health.
What wave is this?
Uh I don't know if it has the off tick.
It could trap this thing. Nine health.
Okay.
If it blood barrages this,
Okay, blood barrage.
Did spec.
I think that was a blowpipe spec for
health.
I don't know. Are they off ticked?
Oh, it's good. They're off ticked.
We going to You can blood barrage this.
Why are we not blood barraging this?
Okay, we're running super freaking far
away.
I don't know. Did it off tick them
intentionally or did it just get lucky?
Okay, it did just kill the bat very
intentionally.
And it died. It missed a flick.
Right? Yeah, it missed a flick.
Uh its inventory does not get reset.
That's solid progress.
Uh do I want to check the sweep real
quick?
The first few runs of it to make sure
it's good. I think that I'll do that and
I'll call it a stream.
>> Why is Inferno not on here?
Huh?
All right, this is the last thing and
then we'll call it. I just want to see
the first few runs.
Okay.
0.7
I got you should do like a much smaller
project than this.
Like not vibe coding the crap out of it.
You'll learn much more.
That is like the most gratuitous loading
ever.
yellow path
Uh
There's no yellow path.
Oh, it was literally spawned next to.
Cool.
You should just do it. You should do us
like a substantially smaller project,
man, and just do it like if you didn't
do this whole thing
Actually, you probably still
animations are tough in 3D. You could
probably do like a top-down 2D version
of this not too far off yourself.
And it would be a much easier little
project to do.
Is Velo?
I'll give him a couple minutes and
otherwise I'm I'm hopping off.
Hey Vault, perfect.
I uh I almost didn't see you. I was
doing the freaking uh
Forester event
on leagues.
So, let me tell you the the ones that
I've seen. First of all, uh the major
respawns nibblers.
Um you can barrage the shield. That
one's not that big of a deal.
Uh what else? Uh the resetting is weird
for sure.
Running a sweep on fight caves, home
stretch and PR.
Oh, yeah.
And the two different RS environments,
we're going to be able to figure out
everything between the two of them.
I also I removed some of your rewards
and I still got it to do Zark.
I probably have to change one small
thing cuz it will milk an extra couple
of waves for damage points before it
bothers to um
to finish Zark. It'll literally leave it
at one T bow shot from dead.
And then it'll just like wait until it
runs out of shield health from fighting
um mage range waves.
Yeah, but Vault, this is like this
trained in 3 minutes.
And this is not the best either.
We have um
the sweep now has us to wave 49.
I was it 49?
Maybe more.
I've seen it do it knows how to blood
barrage blobs, it knows how to freeze
melees, it knows how to prioritize major
because it knows the major respawn
stuff.
It knows quite a bit of stuff.
the main stuff I wanted to talk about
I can also chat on on Discord voice if
you want whenever.
Um
the main thing is I had I had a
different branch. I pushed it to a
separate branch. I didn't merge it.
Where I messed with the observations a
whole bunch.
And I removed a bunch of stuff that
should be redundant.
And training was still working just
fine.
But I wasn't able to check it on that
one.
Because I didn't have the rendering
working.
So, I think we do this sweep.
Uh I let this sweep run. I see how far
it gets and then maybe we work on if we
can get that merging, it'll get us quite
a bit of speed back and maybe even make
it train a little bit better.
I essentially I reduced the obs size by
a factor of like three.
So, with that, I think the only thing
that'll be the speed bottleneck will be
the pathing.
Should stream league.
This is the the league progress from day
one.
X blocking.
Uh did you get to what kills it
typically is leaving mage hits?
Um
Yeah, so I did I watched the full thing.
It eventually got chipped down by just
tons of spawns things to
uh things to flick. And I can't tell if
it missed a flick on it was flicking a
major and a ranger and I couldn't tell
if it missed a flick or if it
accidentally same ticked them or if it
like stepped in melee. But it made like
one small mistake.
But overall, the policy quality is very
high and I have not like this one was
not even swept. So, I think with like a
little bit of additional sweep and um
a little bit longer training, we'll be
able to see a much more stable version
of the policy and then the errors will
be way clearer, right? Cuz it'll be way
less random and when it makes an error,
there'll be a better reason for it.
Any tips to write symbols in C? Look at
all of our sims.
Uh I don't really review websites. I'm
not a web dev.
We do RL in C.
Like we have lots of example Ms in C
though.
You should have four for that.
Just take a look at our examples.
What steps are you going to sweep to?
Yeah, so Vault, we don't actually have
to do that anymore. Like we just have a
really I deleted your entire sweep
config and I'll just use the default
sweep config. It automatically takes
care of allocating more or less budget
based on the performance.
You pretty much don't have to mess with
that.
You couldn't find symbols in puffer lip
GitHub. They're in the ocean.
All these.
Some of them are higher quality than
others. So, just ask around for which
ones are good. Snake is a super simple
one to look at.
Um
what else is decent? Breakout is easy
enough to look at. There are a lot of
them that are quite easy to look at.
>> Yeah, I noticed there's quite a bit of
reward Ange on um
on like Zuck and stuff and it's really
not needed.
Like I removed the stand behind shield
reward. It just learns that instantly.
Um I removed the stay alive reward. It
learns that as well.
Like a lot of the stuff it'll just kind
of learn.
Oops, I've been not super out there.
I think that you just thought that it
needs like a way bigger policy and way
more steps than it actually needs. Like
Puffer is really really good RL.
Um
it just doesn't need
as heavy stuff as you expected is all.
I guess I can show you Let's Let's train
the Zuck fight real quick.
So all I did is I started 69, is it? Or
is it 68? 69, right?
Rewards when all obs are faulty. Yeah,
so that's like a common failure mode in
RL vault is people will like mess with
the rewards a whole bunch, but when you
have good stable RL, you really don't
need to mess with the rewards a ton of
and unless you have deceptive rewards,
you probably have crappy observations.
Custom model arch.
Sending what Puffer does roughly. Yeah.
And that kind of goes in line with a lot
of the lit that you'll see, but the
thing is their RL is just way worse and
way slower than Puffer's.
You kind of just don't need to do very
much when you have the core stable.
It just sort of works.
Oh yeah, it also it you don't actually
need to be behind the shield 100% of the
time either. It'll just like, you know,
dip behind the shield for the tick that
Zuck fires.
It's very comfortable just standing out
in front of the shield and I actually
noticed that it dodges most of the
healer damage.
exponentially
We don't increase X number of obs
exponentially.
It's just very fast, so we can train on
a ton of obs.
It's technically it's a constant factor.
Aditya, it's just a really big constant
factor. It's just like a flat 1,000 to
10,000 X faster that for very small
networks.
And it's still like 100 X faster for
medium sized nets for a lot of things.
It's going to use stuff that's way out
there on Zuck.
Oh yeah.
Well,
I don't know, the top players are really
really good at the game vault.
Like the top players are just really
really good.
Here, we can watch Zuck.
Where do you put my robotic arm if I
write the simulation? Yep.
You put a you can get a robotics into
Puffer.
It's not our primary focus, but you can
absolutely do it.
It's kind of just the same.
So it is bowing here. It's just that the
um for some reason it does the mage
animation and fires the arrow.
It also likes to tag the major before
the ranger, I noticed.
I wonder if the major can respawn the
ranger.
Hey Vault, you should check if the major
can respawn the ranger in the Zuck wave
because I think that's probably why it's
tagging the major first, right? Cuz like
why else would you do that?
How casually tick perfect it is. Yeah.
I'm honestly surprised it hasn't
bothered flicking mage range at the
moment.
They're off ticked, right?
I guess it depends when they see you.
[clears throat]
Oh, I do Are they same ticked right now?
Mm, I don't know.
Low animation.
Does it wonky for
Huh.
Yeah, no, it's not high priority Vault.
I think like when we if we have it like
doing the whole thing super well, then
we can figure out other things.
They're always off ticked unless you do
something weird. Oh, okay, I see.
Yeah, I've never bothered trying to
flick that.
All right, here comes Jad.
Is it actually using offensives here?
Cuz prayer drain is really fast.
It really likes to kill um all the
healers cuz it gets This is why damage
reward can be bad
cuz it's just going to farm all these
healers.
You know?
Offensive or auto?
I see.
Basic scaffolding.
Mm.
They might need more prayer pots then.
If it's just camping offensive does
offensives,
then um
that's a lot of prayer points.
I don't even think you can camp
offensives for a whole Inferno, can you?
All right, here comes healers. Watch
this.
>> It did a couple blowpipe hits and then
it also uh is barraging them for
whatever reason.
Uh we're going to bow zuk in between cuz
we can't reach the healer.
And now we're going to blowpipe the
healer.
Is the blowpipe on rapid? I actually
can't tell
if it's three tick.
Healers aren't healing. They're tagged
for free it looks.
Ah.
Well, that's a big difference.
I actually I thought I made that change
Vault, but I didn't push that to your
main. I pushed that to a separate
branch.
And I don't have it on this branch.
Shouldn't at least.
It looks kind of slow to me cuz I've
never seen it do the like the one-step
blow
the uh the two-step blowpipe walk.
Weird cuz it uses um in the full runs it
will use the blowpipe correctly on
blobs.
But this is basically it. Any other
questions, Vault?
Anything else I can help? Because if
not, I'm going to let the sweep run and
I'm just going to go back to leagues.
I've done all the random AFK tasks
already.
I saw it hit a 49 on something one time.
I think I saw it hit a 49 on a ranger
one time and I have no idea how it did
how it did that.
We could also probably give it some
better gear.
And it can't be brewed down cuz I didn't
give it any brews.
I think we're good. Got to fix the bugs
you brought up. So, I pushed a couple
branches for you. The sweep 35 branch is
the sweep starting from wave 35. I also
pushed the zuk branch. It's basically
the exact same thing.
Um we can clean that up. Oh yeah, by the
way, it will eventually kill this thing.
It's milking another wave right now is
what it's doing.
So, it can get the extra damage on the
melee on the um ranger and major.
And then it'll eventually just boop like
do the last T bow shot after that.
For football, can it come up with
tactics?
We do sort of similar stuff to that
professionally.
Um the thing is like
the game actually has to have reasonable
opportunities for tactical improvement.
I don't know how much football as a
sport is limited by tactics.
It's really smart about reward hacking.
Yeah, Vault, so this is another reason
why you don't come up with fancy-ass
reward functions cuz it'll do [ __ ] like
this. The poppers just smarter than you.
How do I sweep a set of values
without default? You either override it,
Weston,
like if you want to sweep it as
something else or you delete it, yeah.
It's one small limitation of the any
file structure. I didn't think it was
big enough a deal to care about.
So yeah, it won here, right?
Or did it lose? I didn't see.
It doesn't get rewarded much for
winning, so
there you go.
All right. I think I'm good for the the
time being. I got the full the full six
GPU box running against uh Inferno.
So, we should get some nice weights out
of it. I don't They'll probably take a
little longer to train.
You know, I wouldn't be surprised we get
ourselves a decent set of like 15 to
20-minute training weights out of it.
Um
and then if you fix some stuff, I'll
just rerun the best config with the
fixes and we'll see if that makes any
sense.
And I'm hoping that we can get a 35 wave
35 through zuk run with this.
That'd be really good.
Change the fight in any way, just a bit
longer. Yeah.
All right. Well, thank you, folks. I'm
going to chill for the day.
See you around.